[موسيقى]
المقاتله السوفيتيا ميكس 17 هي مقاتله تم
تخصيصها لمهام الاعتراض والاسناد الجوي
القريب دخلت هذه المقاتله الخدمه في سلاح
الجو السوفيتي في العام 1952 لتحل محل
مقاتله الملك خمسه عشر حيث تركزت مهامها
على اعتراض القاذفات الاستراتيجيات
متعه الميكس 17 بقدره كبيره على المناوره
امام المقاتلات الامريكيه هذه القدره
مكنتها من اسقاط عدد من الطائرات
الامريكيه المتقدمه حينها مثل مقاتله
كانت الميكس 17 هي المقاتله الاساسيه
لسلاح الجو المصري وكذلك سلاح الجو السوري
في حرب اكتوبر من عام
1973 بل ونجحت بالفعل في اسقاط عدد من
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه اثناء الحرب
[موسيقى]
صنع من هذه المقاتله اكثر من عشره الاف
نسخه كما خدمت في كثير من الدول حول
العالم كما قامت ايضا الصين وكوريا
الشماليه بتصنيعها لكن تحت مسميات مختلفه
وبترخيص من الاتحاد السوفيتي هذا قبل ان
تخرج من الخدمه في اواخر ثمانينيات القرن
الماضي
[موسيقى]